are you confused with all this talk
about AI well have no fear America our
brave vice president is on the case
Kamala convening a Roundtable with labor
and civil rights leaders to discuss
artificial intelligence and boy did she
really get to the heart of the issue
AI is kind of a fancy thing it's first
of all it's two letters it means
artificial intelligence but
ultimately what it is is it's about
machine learning
and so the machine is taught
and part of the issue here is what
information is going into the machine
[Music]
but here's someone who actually knows a
thing or two about technology Elon Musk
launching his own AI company to compete
with chat GPT after pledging to fight
liberal bias in the field
all right Jesse you know Kamala Harris
talks to all of us like we're five years
old and since she did such a great job
on the border do you think she should be
the aisr yeah I think she is right she
was in the meeting and Joe was not yeah
the funny thing about Kamala is that she
thinks we're all stupid but we actually
think she's stupid and she talks to us
like we're stupid because every time she
says something she has to explain it
remember when she explained the Ukraine
situation yeah Ukraine is a country
Russia is a bigger country she did that
with culture they asked her what's
culture culture is a reflection
of the moment in time and now she's
doing this with AI it's not her job to
talk down to us I don't know what her
job is but she's not doing it and I
guess maybe she thinks whoever she's
talking to are idiots
you know Harold the Democrats they know
that Joe Biden you know he's he's older
and let's say he gets elected again I
mean you see that woman being president
of the United States a Heartbeat Away
can you see her in a meeting with Putin
I mean she's going to tell him these
countries near Ukraine well she needs to
brush up a little bit on AI and get a
better summary when she's asked when
she's asked these questions I think the
latter part of what you talked about
with with Mr musk or Elon and what he's
doing in this space uh and we we've had
a lot of conversations around this table
about it AI is going to be incredibly
positive for the country in so many ways
from making things more efficient
including in healthcare and medicine but
there's so many downsides to it or
things we've got to be concerned about
and we've talked about here and she she
was right in one regard she just didn't
said right it's it's about the kind of
information you feed this machine and we
are now talking about ways to feed these
machines to like us as humans uh till
we're trying to show them the benefit of
of humanity as we know it so they won't
kill us and I was pleased to see that
you put up my my twin robot in your
intro
with the shape of my head it's like a
Blue Man Group okay
there it is
nice to be around the table everybody
thank you very much that kills me all
right well um you know Greg the truth is
that
you know one of the things that Harold
said was kind of stunning I mean are
they going to kill us well that's the
thing I mean you can't explain
artificial intelligence cannot be
explained by artificial intelligence and
this in the Herald's right man this is
too important yeah this is a big deal
and that's the one they're handing it
over to the well you know there's two
letters that's how far she's got you
know what it is it's like she is that
person that never does any research
doesn't do the homework but if you just
talk really slow and you just say the
obvious you know AI
two letters
stands for artificial intelligence but
what does that really mean thesaurus
where's the thesaurus it's machine
learning you're good at that thank you
no I think that yeah I think that I
could probably listen to YouTube
I think just going slow and just like
yeah right fine but nobody but us point
this points this stuff out blows my mind
that you have one of the most comical
political people in recent history I
mean I mean for the for I mean obviously
Trump provided a lot of a lot of content
for the left but like this person should
provide content for everybody because
it's so buffoonery yeah yeah you know
you know Dana 76 of Americans want AI
regulated 59 of them think that you know
the the government uh is not capable of
doing it properly at 39 things it
doesn't have the ability to do it
properly and 32 percent have a positive
view of Kamala Harris right so we're
getting down to the numbers here and I
think it's wonderful and amazing and
great and this is the American way this
is how it should work that Elon Musk is
saying okay I couldn't get the pause
remember the six months pause that he
wants I'm fine I'll start my own company
and he hired three really genius people
from all these other companies he's
hired them away so now they can fight it
out in the marketplace and I think that
that's good now does anybody here think
Washington's really going to help
they're so far behind they're not ready
so you should call upon the people who
are working on this and maybe be out
there in Silicon Valley a little bit
more or make them come to you and if I
were her what I would this is what I
used to do I used to hate talking about
the budget more than anything and I
would have to give the briefing okay
about the budget when the president's
budget came out and you have to learn
all the numbers and you know it's not
going to pass anyway so I wouldn't ever
want to do it so what do you do this is
she has the power to ask anybody in the
world to join her at the podium to say I
am leading this group on artificial
intelligence I just met with the most
amazing group of people they are so
smart they are Patriot they are leading
the charge on this there are some
opportunities there are some challenges
I'm going to turn this over to these two
people and they're going to explain it
to you please gentlemen go ahead and
then you don't look like a dunce as I
would have if I have been talking about
the budget Greg explain the budget like
Kamala would have
budget the budget is everything
everything
it's not just some things but it's
everything together one time together
together at one time
so important that we have this we have
together at once in one time a budget a
budget but and we do it every year at
one time we do it and we we try to and
that's what's great and that we never
stick to it we never stick to it but up
next the Hollywood star reveals who was
responsible for all this smoke nonsense
will tell you who
I went on Brian Kilmeade I want you to
do me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now